have you ever heard the claim that the
Christian biblical Cannon didn't exist
before the Council of NAA that it was
during this meeting that the books of
the New Testament were decided on
sometimes people even claim that this
decision was made by Emperor Constantine
himself well this is all completely
false but it's a very common
misconception that's spread around
social media in fact the Council of NAA
had nothing to do with the biblical
cannon at all it wasn't discussed to any
degree during this meeting the formation
of the New Testament Cannon did not
happen overnight it was a long organic
process that spans centuries even beyond
the Council of NAA and the 3rd Century
but already by this point when the
council is being held in 3:25 the basic
sort of form or framework for the New
Testament books were already in place
you know they had organically developed
over the centuries so now when you see
someone claiming these inaccurate things
about the Council of NAA you can share
this video with them and we can set some
things straight